BEEN PUSHING BACK HARD.
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL HAS
THAT STORY.
>> CONGRESS DOESN'T HAVE POWER
TO STOP PRESIDENT TRUMP'S NEW
TARRIFS PROPOSAL SO THE FOCUS IS
ON ASKING HIM TO FINE-TUNE IT.
>> MAKE IT MORE TARGETED.
>> SPEAKER RYAN'S COMMENTS ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP TARRIFS ON
ALUMINUM AND STEEL AND A
POSSIBLY TRADE WAR.
>> WE WANT ABUSERS HELD TO
ACCOUNT ESPECIALLY CHINA AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE DON'T
CORRECT ANY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES.
>> REPUBLICANS ARE WORRIED NEW
TARRIFS CAN HAVE A NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON GAINS IN THE ECONOMY
>> THERE IS A LOT OF CONCERN
AMONG REPUBLICAN SENATORS THAT
THIS COULD CHANGE INTO A LARGER
TRADE WAR.
>> SENATE DEMOCRATIC LEADER
CHUCK SCHUMER SAID ACTION SHOULD
BE ON BEIJING.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S INSTINCTS TO
GO AFTER CHINA ARE RIGHT.
CHINA HAS TAKEN TERRIBLE
ADVANTAGE OF AMERICA.
>> A REPUBLICAN SENATOR IS A
FORMER U.S. TRADE
REPRESENTATIVE.
>> IT OUGHT TO BE FOCUSSED ON
PARTICULAR PRODUCTS AND COUNTRY
PARTICULAR PRODUCTS AND COUNTR
COUNTRIES AND NOT BE SO BROAD
BASED.
>> THE TREASURY SECRETARY
DOUBLED DOWN THAT THERE COULD BE
FINE-TUNING FOR NEIGHBORING
TRADE PARTNERS.
>> IN WE ARE SUCCESSFUL IN
RENEGOTIATING NAFTA, THOSE
TARRIFS WON'T APPLY TO MEXICO
AND CANADA.
>> ALLIES WARNED TO THE
PRESIDENT TODAY.
A NEW TAX ON STEEL AND ALUMINUM
WILL COST JOBS, INCREASE COSTS
TO CONSUMERS AND FORCE
BUSINESSES TO GO OVERSEAS.
WE STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
RECONSIDER THIS PROPOSAL.
>> SOME ARE HOPEFUL THAT PUSH
BACK FROM OUTSIDE GROUPS AND THE
MARKETS WILL GET THE ATTENTION